hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
instructive game to share with you from
the 1981 USSR championship
on the white end landed you Dawson and
he's playing against Gary Kasparov
okay opening wise open Sicilian
nightorf
Bishop G5 on this move six is met with
small pond Center
it's not a good idea to go two steps
with the e-pawn and create this hole on
D5 when the number one defender of that
square
is already Under Fire
so it's the small pond Center in this
one
we continue with a pawn Duo hinting at
E5 black cuts that one out
black is also saying I'm welcome to a
structural defect on the king side
we see just that in this game
a case of doubled F pawns and
a minor piece imbalance on the pose dark
Square Bishop
we continue with Bishop E2 Knight C6
met with Knight B3 so this is maybe one
of the first points to speak of in this
game
why is it that white is ducking In The
Night Exchange
there's a couple notes on this one is
space related white enjoys a little bit
more space two fourth rank pawns
competing against three third rank
in general when you have more space you
want to keep more pieces on board you'll
find it easier to maneuver
additionally if white is welcome to the
Knight Exchange
black will find it much easier to assume
a strong Queen post
what am I talking about well let's
suppose instead of Knight B3 Queen D2
was played
this is where we could have the Knight
exchange and this is the strong Queen
post I'm speaking of
Queen on C5 patrolling this fifth rank
watching out over multiple Pawn breaks
it's worth noting that in the vast
majority of Sicilian positions black is
welcome to a queen exchange is welcome
to
in endgame especially in this case here
playing with the bishop pair
the suggestion by the engine in this
position is to go back to D2
and what we have a very good Queen post
for black we might describe it as a
fourth ranked queen versus a second rank
Queen
one final note taking in this position
on F6 as white is met well with Rook G8
multiple pieces get activated the rook
and you can be sure that unopposed
Bishop will be getting on the main
diagonal very shortly thereafter
okay
in this game it is Knight B3 I guess a
more simplistic way to view it is white
keeps a mask over the black queen she
can't see along the C file
okay from here B5
and now Bishop to H5
so I have a few things to note with
Bishop to H5
first of all
the computer suggestion instead of this
move
is a fan of A3
and then next kingside castles
if you're playing A3
and queen side castles uh those two
moves
typically don't go well with each other
you're subjecting yourself to some Pawn
break and an open file towards your king
okay in any case no A3 no stabilizing
the knight in this game
he goes with Bishop H5 so what is that
move doing
the first thing that crosses my mind is
oh there's a pin on the F Pawn and it
may seem on the surface that's not a big
deal
what could be right around the corner
are these ideas by white to try and
punch a hole in one of the center
squares
because the F Pawn is pinned nearby
there can be these ideas of playing F5
and then a capture on E6
in those cases black pretty much wants
to be in a spot to recapture with the
pawn
so that D5 is still secure so that this
guy doesn't kill you
this guy is allowed to get to D5 your
debt
okay so these ideas
are there
proceed with caution
be timely black is timely in this
position he goes with Bishop 2 G7
you could feed keto either Bishop both
seem like yeah what's the difference
there's a difference
if you go with
the queen side fiend keto instead
here's how white could continue
Queen G4 is basically telling the king
where to go
you can't Castle kingside now
Far and Away the best move in this
current position it says go Queen side
castles right now
do you want a castle on this side as
black you don't have any pawns around on
your seventh rank as cover they have
drifted so black can certainly
experience some long-term issues by
being castled on the queen side
what does black play in this game he
goes with the King side fiancado and now
meets Queen G4 with
kingside castles he's okay being in this
pin he knows that it is still a long way
off for white before there's this idea
to form a battery getting some Rook to
G3 looking at some mate
okay
Queen side castles in this game
is met with
my favorite move of the game
97 the first retreating move by black in
this game
why do I like this move
um
I think in this position it seems like
you know it's it's not a robotic move
what do I mean by that well it's the
opening I'm supposed to develop the
undeveloped pieces so you put the bishop
here that way your Rooks are connected
no black recognizes what is most
important he's anticipating certain
threats by white and he's also looking
at what is most important or more
important
what's more important in this position
is to try to find a way to activate your
unopposed dark Square Bishop Knight E7
is a step in that direction
this move is supporting an F5 Pawn break
you could be sure when he developed his
Bishop to G7
he didn't intend on Staring at this Pawn
for the remainder of the game he wants
to get this guy out of the way so that
the bishop can see the world
additionally this is in a way a
defensive move against ideas by white
Rook D3 Rook G3
the move played in this position is
Knight D4
if white plays Rook D3 how can black
react F5
and after Pawn takes there's Knight
takes and this Rook cannot get to G3
time sensitive position to be sure
okay in this game it's Knight D4 we have
a little jocking of positions uh between
blacks Queen knight and king Knight in
this game
how did this play out
black played Knight C6 when the Knight
was on D4 and then the Knight went to B3
and now the Knight went to E7 and white
is like okay I'll go back to D4
they keep ducking one another
all right from here where do we go well
very instructive follow-up play here
this 24 move game
very forceful play
Pawn play first black drives the night
away
from this sensitive Square D5
and now continues with F5 he's not
making some slower move like hey I don't
like pins let me get out of the pin no
forceful F5 get out of the way my Bishop
wants to see
I'm gonna maybe try and kick you off of
the G file you'll go away on your own
possibly
okay white continues with the capture on
F5
how do we recapture
we don't
E5
this square is now clogged up there's
also now a pin on the pond we're getting
a pawn break in black is with this
sequence of moves breaking down
the dark squares he's carving out
potentially a square for a bishop he's
ready to clear this main diagonal
white takes
black recaptures with the pawn
Queen G5 is hinting at now F6 now that
there's no longer this pin
black says go away H6 white goes back
this guy is pinned
Queen would fall
there's also no longer this pin here so
this is still nearby F6 well
Knight takes on F5
Knight takes Knight and
Bishop
takes Knight we're just recapturing now
isn't wasn't it just seven moves ago I
believe where there was the possibility
to just develop the bishop to B7
you know working on getting all your
pieces activated
connecting your Rooks
look at how this turns out it's weird
how this is just all coming together
that's the way you develop your Bishop
doesn't really get any better than that
you are with this move recapturing a
piece and yeah all of a sudden
generating a pretty serious threat
mate in one
the initiative is blacks it has been
winning for many moves now this is only
a 24 move game white is busted
perfect play here
we continue with Rook D2 defending C2
Rook C8
Queen B3
he didn't have to spend a move
with King to h8 to get out of the pin
white was pulled away distracted because
of this aggressive play because he's
King in on C2 the queen had to be pulled
away all on her own
from here E4
the unopposed dark Square Bishop sees
the world
nearby
E3 to scare away The Rook C2 collapses
white tries King to B1 many ways to win
from here E3 is one way to do it
Queen takes Bishop takes C2 is a winning
continuation in this game though
one more retreating move Bishop E6
throwing a serious punch of course
where do we go here with the queen
if in this position you play Queen A4
Can you spot an excellent move here
feel free to pause the video
okay an excellent move would be
Queen E5
threatening mate and yeah this guy over
here on H5 is also hanging
two threats
Black's gonna win a piece
so
what is tried Queen G3 trying to get the
Queens off
black says Nope one more move and then
resignation Can you spot the final move
feel free to pause the video
all right here we go
only the second step with the black
queen in this game Queen A5
and white resigns
the bishop is still hit whether the
queen is on E5 coordinating with the
bishop on B2
or A5
Bishop is hit and from this post she is
now coordinating with the light Square
Bishop completely busted position for
white
the beast from Baku made it look very
very easy in this one
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye